hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
Monday Monday
March 13th
2023 how are you how was your March
going
you know it's unlucky March 13th
doesn't have to be a Friday
why did that always happen Friday the
13th oh wait a minute was that because
Jesus did Jesus get whacked on a Friday
he did didn't he and then three days
later he came back now it would have
been a Monday
Saturday Sunday Monday
yeah you got to do it on the weekend
where people are around to see the rock
roll back right you can't do it on a
Monday everybody's at [__] work
although they had slaves back then so
they probably never gave them a [__]
day off so probably Monday didn't make
much of difference
did they go to church on Sunday before
Jesus what was going on didn't that was
back when they like [__] had the tree
guard and the [__] grass God the sky
God
the god of The reigns
you know when God was more Diversified
you know
and then all those pedophiles all got
together and they were like no no no
there's only one God
and we talked to him
and everybody was like yeah I'm not
doing that [__] and they go all right
well then we're gonna [__] torture
you to death
you know because we're super religious
and we're trying to Sith
this is all old [__] everybody's gone
through this bill shut the [__] okay
sorry
I don't know what why is Friday the 13th
unlucky I'm gonna say it was Jesus
you know
you had a bunch of great days it seems
as Buddha there's really nothing like
you know he didn't have to [__]
there's always something there's a
drought
you know
there was always something they always
kind of went through something a
Buddhist just
you know he's a he's a gamer
sitting on the couch
this big belly heating some [__]
Fritos or whatever
old school Fritos back when it was real
Fritos not this synthetic Frito [__] all
right hang on a second why
is Friday
what are your guess putting you got your
Friday the 13th brackets ready Friday
the 13th unlucky here we go and the
first answer
oh my God CNN this is gonna be like a 20
[__] pitch you know there's a Friday
every week [__] 10 minutes later can
you just answer the [__] question
here we go why is Friday the 13th
unlucky you typed according to biblical
Traditions 13 guests attended the Last
Supper
held on Monty
Monday Thursday
Monday Thursday yada what the [__]
m-a-u-n-d-y
including Jesus and his Twelve Apostles
one of whom betrayed Judas betrayed him
see the math doesn't work out on that
so if one guy was a [__] and the other
11 looked the other way
how do you include Jesus on that the
next day of course was Good Friday oh he
did die on a Thursday
the day of Jesus crucifixion
on the third day rose again so he came
back on a Monday
it's a pretty good work ethic
took the weekend off
yeah listen yeah you got to go back down
there
um
what is Mandy see this is like what
happens you know I was talking to Joe
bartnick this weekend and we were both
laughing
about the word meta
and for the life of me I just can't
[__] remember what it means and then
when somebody explains it to me I still
don't get it
it's like what is meta it means oh it's
commenting on itself and it's like okay
what is what does that mean
all right Mandy
could somebody just in in layman's terms
meaning dumb person terms can you
explain to me what that means because
that's oh yeah did you see it oh It's So
Meta
it's aware of itself
okay we're getting closer okay the
ceremonial washing of the feet
of poor persons
in the commemoration of Jesus washing of
his disciples feet
wait this I'm Christian I don't know
this do we wash poor people's feet
not where I live they're like when you
get this [__] Tent City out of here
what they can take their tents and their
dirty feet and take a [__] hike
that's that's how it happens
out here in Los Angeles right
they need to do something about the
homeless
when people say that not help them they
mean get the [__] out of here all right
held on Monday Thursday okay 13 guests
attended the Last Supper held on Monday
Thursday so they were out washing
poor people's feet
God how dirty were feet back then
Jesus was in the year 32 like those must
have been some
you know and you didn't have any there
was no brushes
oh boy
did they have soap back then
including this is how you just lose half
a [__] day on the internet
including Jesus and his 12 Apostles one
of whom was Judas Judas betrayed him
all right wait a second
this is the last one I'm going to ask
that I was going to get off my [__]
life here
all right
by the way I'm up to Pimsleur level five
of my French and I'm getting my ass
kicked in the past
and future tenses somewhere along the
line I missed something and I'm just
really getting killed so I gotta like
stop and figure out what's going on I
think I need to get a tutor again all
right when was
soap
invented
2800 BC all right
okay there we go
all right
evidence has been found
oh my God can you imagine somebody
digging around the dirt just being able
to know that
look at this what is this I don't know a
stone I don't know
I think this is
I think this is prehistoric soap
how the [__] would you know that
and then you can kind of predict the
year
see this is why
when there's people that level's smart
out there
this is which has really
makes most of the internet confusing to
me but that's part of being dumb part of
being dumb is you think you [__] know
[__]
like I went I went to 12 [__] years
of grade school you know had a little
bit of college or maybe even had College
just walking around it's [__] no [__]
this guy doesn't know what the [__] he's
talking about that's one of my favorite
things I heard growing up
yeah this guy doesn't know what the [__]
yeah what do you say
ah yeah
what I was talking about
how come he doesn't know what he's
talking about he's in that field because
he said he gave me an answer I didn't
want to hear
hence he doesn't know what the [__] he's
talking about
it's really amazing
um
all right
all right strongest since 2015. oh
that's what I wanted to talk about I've
been going back to the gym
I'm back
um I am the strongest I have been since
2015 when I first [__] up my shoulders
I am ecstatic
I am gradually working my way
through being able to climb up a rope
again like I used to do back in the day
getting some grip strength pull-ups all
of that [__] I've lost most of my
coveted weight
the other night I did a show and I
busted out some shirt I haven't worn
like three four years
I know what you're thinking hey Bill
wasn't a little out of style I've always
been out of style
you know you know it was funny it was a
one of those western style shirts that
had like snaps on it
which uh I was in shape to wear that
shirt's standing up but when I sat down
you know when you wear a shirt with
snaps on it like if you're fat or too
fat for the shirt it like bunches up and
then you know your your mistakes kind of
poke through
[Laughter]
sitting there after my show hanging out
with some people thinking you know all
right that was a good show these people
had a good time whatever and I just
looked down and I just saw you know a
box of Girl Scout cookies
[__] poking out of my shirt I was
just like yeah God I'm a [__] loser
but um I've been really doing really
well like uh I am
somebody finally explained what sugar
does to your body
and I have that in my head every time I
think of doing something stupid like I
went out with my lovely wife today
um
doing what I wanted to do during this
break going out to dinner with her
seeing movies or whatnot
and um
went to this great restaurant
and in the end she wanted to order she
goes ah because you want to split a
dessert and I was like no I'm I'm off
I'm off the sugar
it spikes your glucose and when your
glucose is spiked it stops it stops
burning fat
and then you just sort of retain it
something like that the guy said
something like that I just don't I just
know I don't want to spike my glucose
if I did that I would be meta
then somebody have to wash my feet on
[__] wash your dirty feet Thursdays
um
that'd be a good thing for guys to do
like every Thursday [__] take a bath
and scrub your [__] toenails
you know what I mean
women go women go to the uh
the foot place right they're allowed to
do that you can't do that as a guy at
least as a white guy it's really looked
down on Pawn I will tell you black guys
do it though at least the black guys I
was hanging out with a long time ago and
I did the rich [__] tour with the late
great Charlie Murphy Donnell Rawlings
uh
uh Rich Murphy was on it I remember one
day they were all going to the spa
to get [__] their nails done I swear
to God
and I was laughing and they're going no
man you should come man [__] dirty
ass white boy walking around I'm like
what's wrong with my nails they're clean
like no you got to get like a manicure
so you know I was a fan of the Pope
Greenwich Village and I remember when
Mickey Rourke was sitting in the
barbershop
what killed me was he looked so clean
but he was smoking his cigarette so you
know instantly he smelt like a [__]
ashtray but he had this great suit on
he's [__] great lead in a movie actor
here and then he was getting a haircut
or something like that the shave and
everything that someone was doing his
nails
because he was going to go down and talk
to bed bug bed bug Eddie so I'm like all
right
I like the pope of Greenwich Village all
right I'll go down and I'll do this
stuff it was [__] hilarious
I sat across from these guys as they had
their hands like soaking in the thing I
was [__] I was probably the most
immature I've ever been I was just
laughing my ass off the entire time and
then I got the only time I've ever
gotten a manicure and I couldn't wait to
scrape that [__] off my fingers
like when we did the show that night I
was waiting for someone in the crowd
so yeah you got your nails done
start getting heckled it was really
outside my wheelhouse
um
I don't even know how I even started
talking about this oh yeah every
Thursday you know that's a big thing
though
I'll tell you younger fellas out there
you younger guys you know you hook up
with some broad you don't want to have
like dirty toenails
you know if you got clean feet
that's that's a good goddamn move man
you don't want to show over there show
up there like you know like Jesus needs
to come back from the dead again on on a
[__] Thursday and watch your goddamn
feet
all right why don't you guys do that
how about every Thursday
you know you look down especially if you
wear black socks if you wear black socks
like if at least you have big toes are
gonna be a mess after three four days
um
this is what this podcast has come to
I'm just giving grooming tips at this
point
um football season's over
my kids dominate the television and I
just keep taping [__] the Bruins are
having their best regular season ever
and I know they lost today five to three
I know they were down two nothing the
other night against I think they had a
home at home against the Red Wings they
came back and won
maybe three to two I don't know what
talk to bartnick about that so I kind of
know what's going on but I have no idea
what the [__] is going on
um
so now I've just started I'm gonna like
tape the games because at night they're
always you know
my kids are always like you know
I don't you know if when I've done it so
I started I started shutting them off
like but I don't want to put Sports on
because they were starting to resent
Sports and they were saying that they
were boring because they're young you
know what I mean they don't understand
like what's going on yet so
I don't want to turn them off to sports
because then you know I'm gonna have to
get the TV out in the garage and just be
that Dad that
you know in 10 years when they're doing
whatever the [__] they're doing it's
like oh dad's watching sports go out to
the garage Dad
no one cares about your sports right
so
um
but lately I've sort of been shutting
off their shows and I'll put on like
ESPN
try to tape a few few things you know
I got the hiccups
um is that meta
me commenting on the hiccups
um no I take this thing uh an Unholy
rivalry or something it was about the uh
the Yankees and Dodgers back-to-back
World Series in 77-78 they should have
added 81. when Fernando came in and put
him over the top
um
but I just love
that uh
that's when I I think that sounds like
the first World Series that I watched
the entire thing I vaguely remember the
75 series and my dad and my grandfather
when he was still alive cheering
I vaguely remember that but um the World
Series I really want to see
if anybody knows where there's like
highlights or anything you can send it
to me I would love it is the
um
the 1976 World Series when the Big Red
Machine after beating the Red Sox
in a seven game
Thriller came back the next year
and uh beat the New York Yankees four
games to none just swept them
um they did not have Reggie Reggie a lot
of people forget I believe was on the
Baltimore Orioles that year
um because that guy in the A's didn't
want to pay anybody
so he he must have played at least a
year there because there is a baseball
card of him playing on the Orioles
um which was just before my time and
then of course they came back and won by
the way when I saw Serpico last week
there's two incredible Stadium one at
New York City College
um Up In Harlem and right after they
shot the movie they uh
they leveled it and put a building up a
really cool looking old stadium I
thought for half a second they were at
um what is that Ivy League school God
knows I don't know those Cornell is that
it
all begins with a C
um Colombia
Colombia right I think it's Colombia
I thought that's where they were but
they were actually at New York City
College or something like that and then
there's another great great unbelievable
shot of the original Yankee Stadium
right before they redid that one
and turned it into the one you know it
became the house of Reggie Jackson
um whenever I think of these set they
remodeled
original Yankee Stadium I just remember
those Dodger Yankee World Series games
and
that white ball just disappearing into
the black Sky after Reggie hit it and
then it just Landing
in the center field seats and my
favorite thing now to listen to was how
Howard Cosell totally steps on Keith
Jackson's call he must have wanted to
[__] kill him
Keith Jackson's like oh Reggie Jackson
there's that deep Fly ball out to
Centerfield and as he's doing that
Howard costell's going that's gone that
ball is gone it is gone Reggie Jackson
his third home run an unprecedented I
can't remember exactly what he said but
he just [__]
jumped all over that call on purpose a
total [__] [__] move and I would love
to hear a recording of Keith Jackson
calling his agent after that game
I'm
I'm not out of the [__] Upper Deck
um
literally jumps all over that [__]
call
[Music]
um
so anyway
um oh I just got an email that has some
new stand updates ladies and gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen
you sound like Jamie Masada ladies and
gentlemen Billy bear Billy bear ladies
and gentlemen
um
he does it every time he calls me
the [__] is what the hell is my damn
email
all right oh there it is
oh I got some new dates I got some new
dates
for you guys oh Billy's going back on
tour
um show information Saturday June 24th
2023 Newark New Jersey at the Prudential
Center 8 P.M Sunday August 13 2023. holy
[__] Oh Canada
Halifax Nova Scotia at the Halifax
Citadel Garrison grounds at 8 pm
um
the pre-sale I think for both of those
is going to be Wednesday
March 15th at 10 A.M local time
I don't know what that means
I would say I would always guess 10 a.m
East Coast the artist's code is Burr
b-u-r-r the general sale is on Friday
March 17th at 10 A.M local time March
17th this Friday everybody
and everybody puts on their [__]
plastic hats right and they start
singing they're green alligator and the
long neck goose
[__] amateur night
once again
um St Patrick's Day is the Valentine's
Day of boozing
[Music]
is a completely made up holiday I know
they're they're acting like they're
showing respect to Irish people but
they're not
with those stupid plastic hats I know I
say this every year
um you know if you're gonna go out
drinking what you want to do go out on
the 18th that's when you want to go well
I would actually wait for the puke smell
to be mopped up maybe go out on the 19th
or maybe that Monday night because it
falls on Friday
this year so there's all that's that is
going to be
um I don't even know if there's really
[__] I don't even know what these kids
do nowadays
I don't think they I don't think that
they're drinking the way we used to
drink
which is a good thing because boost was
the only thing legal and now there's
just so much [__] legal [__] it's
incredible
it really is incredible and I have to be
honest with you like when you could just
[__] sit down
and take two Puffs off some [__]
joint
that is going to send you into the
stratosphere why would you waste all the
energy
trying to down a six-pack or whatever
your [__] choice is
um
I don't know speaking of that
speaking of being social
freckles went to uh the Sofi Stadium on
Friday night
and I saw Stevie Nicks and Billy Joel
and I could not have had a better time
watching those two absolute Legends
crush it absolutely crush it
for uh I don't know how many hours
Stevie Nicks comes out and we're
thinking like all right if she's open
wow she's opening she's just gonna be
like 45 minutes this is going to be
wall-to-wall hits she came out and sort
of was like co-headlining like she came
out and did well over an hour still
played nothing but hits and I was
thinking like you know something she's
gonna do stop dragging my heart around
and she's gonna do this tribute
to um
you know to Tom Petty and all that
that's going to be like a real tear
jerker and all that type of stuff
instead they start playing it and as
they're playing it Billy Joel just comes
walking out and sings Tom Petty's part
everybody goes nuts they killed it they
sounded great together and later on in
her set
um she picked a different song which I
thought was really cool
that she did it then because if she was
shown a bunch of pictures of her and Tom
Petty while Billy Joel was on stage that
would have gotten away
it was like a really like whoever
decided to do it that way was really
smart and she had all these killer
pictures later on in her set of her and
Tom Petty oh the Heartbreak is Stan
Lynch when he was in the band oh my God
I mean those guys would just [__]
top shelf right and then
um then later on
you know I don't want to ruin the show
now I'm thinking I'm ruining the show if
he goes she did another tribute to her
uh was it Christy McVeigh I'm not the
biggest sleep with Mac fan but like
those pictures were enough to make you
tear up you could tell they were sisters
and best friends it was just [__]
awesome and then Billy Joel comes out
and I don't know does two two and a half
hours of nothing but hits
just absolutely destroyed it and I get
another thing too about Billy Joel is
the guy is [__] hilarious
he's so relaxed he's 74 years old
he plays like three number one hits and
then he just kind of looks around it so
far because he's I I'm assuming he's
never been there he just kind of looks
around it's like I don't know how many
tens of thousands of people like [__]
70 000 people are sitting there
screaming he just kind of looks around
he's like
it's a big place
he said it like he was sitting in the
stance not like we were all looking at
him I'm not going to tell you any of his
jokes
um
he was amazing and then later on
you know Stevie Nicks came back I was
funny I was sitting there thinking in
the crowd trying to be the smart guy
like I'm in business and show biz too
the business of show I'm thinking like
when he was like into his 10th song I
was like I bet Stevie Nicks is home
right now taking a bath
you know the most underrated slot in
Show Business opening everybody wants
the headline if you open you get in
there you know the crowd's cool
get it get the [__] out it's fantastic
fantastic I was thinking that when I saw
the Motley Crue Def Leppard thing with
uh poison I was thinking that like Joan
Jett is already back at the hotel
you know ordered a little room service
got the bubble bath going
and these guys are still waiting to [__]
like she's done
she could actually go out if she wanted
to it's [__] fantastic but she she
hung around she came out she sang a song
within the place [__] went nuts and
um
I may or may not have been on mushrooms
not a lot
but I I kind of picked the perfect
amount and uh I was in a real fun
section
you know a lot of Malibu moms a lot of
Malibu people I felt were around me you
know it's a lot of guys with older guys
with ponytails and [__]
uh I went with Josh Adam Meyers dude and
we just had a [__]
we had a great time Billy's band was
killer
um
Stevie's band was killer it was just
like and they were both like such Pros
like both of them took the time not only
to thank everybody for coming out they
acknowledged because it was raining cats
and dogs you know
um and they're like you know thanks for
coming out in the rain and sitting
through all the traffic and all just
that old school
Showbiz [__] like
like they were raised right you know
what I mean so
um
anyway
I highly recommend I'm so psyched that I
saw him
Billy and Stevie because it's like uh
they're still like I'm telling you man
they kiss both of them singing their
[__] asses off 100 worth
the time the money the traffic and all
of that [__] we had such a [__] great
time
you know met these moms from Utah
it's like that crowd like moms bringing
their kids and [__] it was just [__]
fun
a lot of old white dudes playing air
piano which I'd never seen in my life
there was this guy in front of us that
like I don't know he was like older than
me he snuck booze in he had a [__]
fat joint he kept turning around
pointing at people having a great time
and uh oh it was this one guy man he
looked like
he looked like he was like I don't know
how [__] old he was just white hair
and he still had it in a ponytail and he
was smoking the fattest [__] joint
and it was just filling up the whole
section and the security guard was
yelling hey
[Applause]
hey it's looking at the guy being like
dude what the [__] I mean the guy's like
[Music]
he looks like he fought in Korea man
he's still got the ponytail he's keeping
her he can't listen and they literally
walked security goes in there and people
were going like come on man you're not
gonna kick him out are you and then the
security guy goes no no I just got to
talk to him you can't smoke in here it's
no smoking I was like all right
all right
this guy was probably a Woodstock he's
he's not grandfathered in to smoke a
[__] joint
um
you know it was weird though like I
didn't see him after [__] Stevie
Nicks I was kind of concerned I'm like
wait did they throw that guy out did
they do the old hey we're not throwing
them out and then they threw him out
that old [__] trick do these people
still do that trick
um
you know what I was thrilled about on my
street
excuse me taking a drink there somebody
got their driveway repaved
and nobody came by and wrote something
on it
I [__] hate when people do that
you know what I mean I feel like they
should be hunted down and made to
[__] fix the driveway or the sidewalk
you know because it's never anything
cool for some reason graffiti can be
cruel cool and can be like art but
someone who just writes in concrete is
they just write their stupid name
you know or they write like who they're
in love with forever and they write it
in concrete and then like a week later
they [__] break up because they're
only in the seventh grade
um
actually had anxiety because the
driveway was so beautiful it's like look
at that it's perfect there's not one
crack in it
no tree roots have pushed it up
ah
look how smooth that is
this is what happens when you get old
you get into that [__] like oh man
look at that guy's driveway
like I don't want to go through the
headache
of getting a new driveway
or the expense
but I am so envious when the job is
complete I'm just thinking to myself
that guy
or that lady toughed it out
you know with all those trucks [__]
digging it up and Hauling it away and I
thought you were gonna pour it today
okay it's gonna [__] rain deal with
all that [__] then it's [__] over
then you're looking at it go oh man
that's nice
that's a nice [__] smooth slab of
concrete
um all right
let's do some reads here shall we all
right oh look who it is look who it is
it's not Jesus
he hasn't come back to wash your feet
and then yell at you because his dad
made you the imperfect person that you
are and he takes no responsibility for
it
it's not him
now when I say him God is the H is
capitalized right
Jesus always gets the lower case
you know he hit the glass ceiling right
his dad never dies
he's never going to get that [__]
corner office all right zipper cruiser
set
oh in honor of Good Friday which has to
be coming up soon right
let's do we're going to do a little
white church singing here
[Applause]
[Music]
if you were to start a new
sorry business
what would it be
if I would start a new business I would
start a [__] security camera business
that catches these punks writing on old
guys new fresh slab of concrete in their
driveway
I wouldn't have a lot of cases I'd be
that lonely PE with that metal sand that
can cut your [__] fingers off sitting
on my desk with a Matchstick lighter
like Humphrey Bogart The Maltese Falcon
I'd just be sitting there but when the
case came in
you'd know you could depend on me all
right examples taco truck business
that seems like a fun job but those guys
work their [__] asses off and I'm
also thinking the amount of drunks they
have to deal with you know here's to you
taco truck driver
uh a bouncy castle backyard parties and
business
ah God those snot-nosed kids [__]
slobbering all over the things you know
you know there's going to be that one
kid who's like twice the size for his
[__] age either because his kids you
know his parents are over feeding them
or they're just like that giant couple
maybe just see a giant couple like the
woman's like six two and the guy's like
six seven
and they come in with their [__]
giant kid
's walking in looking like a baby
giraffe [__] man torso just slamming
into kids hey he's too big it's only
four
okay I thought he was 15.
all right
let's see an animal rescue shelter
um that's a good one some kind of
Charity some kind of Charity [__]
selling handmade wood products
wow we kind of ran out of businesses
here didn't we you mean knickknacks
whether you're starting a new business
or growing one shout out to people
[__] dealing weed if he wanted to be
successful you need the most talented
people on your team that's where Zippy
comes in
and right now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
sorry why should you let sip yes
help you hire
for your business why should you do that
I'll tell you why relax it's not a
rhetorical question no is it rhetorical
it is a rhetorical question zip recruit
is powerful matching technology finds
highly qualified candidates for a wide
range of roles you got your eye on one
or two people be perfect for your job
don't worry zip
let you send them a personal invite Hey
Big Boy how would you like to type some
letters for me so they're more likely to
apply ZipRecruiter offers also offers
attention grabbing labels that speak to
job flexibility like remote
training provided
urgent
free pistol I'm sorry and more to really
help your job stand out
um
let's zip that fill all your roles with
the right candidates four to five
employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a
quality candidate within the first day
you don't have time is money
if I learned anything from those P Diddy
videos back in the day money never
sleeps yeah what rise and grind 24 7
365. [__]
keep going can't stop won't stop right
sorry my throat is [__] dry
um
I don't even know what I was talking
about
fortify you had a candidate within the
first day you need to get a candidate
within the first day you know something
remember that P Diddy show he had back
in the day where we made those potential
uh Making the Band
you know you know why he doesn't do that
show anymore because he's got [__]
zip recruiter
he can put a band together in one day
see for yourself go to this exclusive
website address to try ZipRecruiter for
free at ziprecruiter.com again that's
ziprecruiter.com spell it out z i p r e
c u i t e r zip recruiter
the smartest way to hire
I Didn't Do It Good zip recruiter
the smartest way to hire oh that was a
good one that's a keeper oh spell out
Burr sorry b-u-r-r
all right game time
you know buying tickets to your favorite
event
s shouldn't be stressful game time
it's the fast and easy way to buy
tickets for all the sports music comedy
and theater near you with killer deals
on last minute tickets and their best
price guarantee you can stop stressing
over the tickets and start getting hyped
for the fun you're going to have
game time is the place for the last
minute ticket deals forget planning
months in advance that's for organized
people you have add this is the ticket
place for you game time
has deals on tickets right up to the day
of the event get exclusive what do you
mean I didn't forget your birthday
I've got [__] tickets to Faster
Pussycat
oh my God I think I'll blow you
um get exclusive fly that really
happened that's an actual example of
someone who used Gametime
it isn't I made it up but whatever I'm
selling it here people I'm being a
professional
um get exclusive Flash Deals on tickets
or football basketball baseball
concerts comedy theater
curling no and more
um the game tab guaranteed means you
will always get the best price if you
find tickets in the same section and row
for Less that's pretty [__] specific
game time we'll credit you a hundred and
ten percent of the difference
then that's just going to give you your
money back they're going to give you a
little Vig like you're a bookie all of a
sudden you know what that's called
people that's called confidence
the kind of confidence you get
game time
it's the fastest growing ticket app in
the country for a reason
get images of your seat before you buy
so you know exactly what to expect when
you arrive well they should put some fat
[__] with a big head in front of us what
they should do buy tickets in a matter
of seconds two Taps and you're set
tickets are sent directly to your phone
so you never have to dig through your
email speaking of which did you see that
chick at the Oscars wearing that [__]
cotton candy around her head
can you imagine you finally get to the
Oscars and then you sit behind that
you're like oh my God
I can't say anything
I'm gonna get suspended like Will Smith
did you have a good time at the Oscars
yeah you know
yeah I mean if the person in front of me
wasn't dressed like they were going to
the Kentucky derp yeah I probably could
have seen something snag the tickets
without the stress stress with Game Time
download the game time app create an
account and use code Burr b-u-r-r for
twenty dollars off your first purchase
terms apply again create an account and
redeem code Burr for twenty dollars off
download game time today last minute
tickets lowest price guaranteed game
time is all one word g-a-m-e-t-i-m-e
all right and with that people I believe
it's time
to go into the reads for the week
um oh and here they are
this is already
this is already interesting to me
Pharaoh Islands
um it sounds like a place where they
would they would have like a uh some
sort of mystery it sounds like they
would be like a horror
genre movie there
or a place where the Discovery Channel
back in the day when they gave a [__]
about nature
before it was just you know people
building [__]
hi my name's [__] crazy [__]
Johnson and I'm into winnebagos we're
here to customize you [__] with him
you know it's like they had fast and
loud then they just did 50 shows just
like it I missed that show
I love that show um feral Islands hey
Bob The Bill Burr oh instead of the
Builder Bob the Bill Burr
um can he fix it I'm sorry in advance if
I [__] up my writing English is one of
my five languages oh Jesus I like it
you speak five languages you're allowed
to
talk a little [__] I mean I can barely
speak this one I just said languages
um I'm a pharaohis
hey you watch how you throw that word
with [__] word around buddy I'm a
pharaoh East 26 year old male who's an
electrician served in the Danish Army
and going to the Danish Navy to be an
electrician
there later this year
all right you're in the Danish Army and
you're going to I was so blown away like
how the [__] does this guy
no English as well
it's amazing considering I'm struggling
so much with my mom Francaise
um
you know what's funny
to my [__]
means you pushed me
you push me
I'm a [__] that means you me push
something like that
I don't know
that one's easy to remember
um all right I probably [__] that up
too uh I'm fairies 26 year old male
who's an electrician served in the
Danish Army and going to the Danish Navy
to be an electrician there later this
year I have a princess daughter who's
four years old oh that's nice look at
you young dad man
she's going to see a lot of your life
that's great well me okay uh um who's
four years old with an ex-girlfriend all
right that's a little rough okay I get
it yeah you know oh my God speaking of
tall couples the [__] Danes
how many meters is this kid already
I know meters is not how you say it but
whatever all right and being in the uh
the Navy will mean I will be two months
at Sea in two months at home with pay
where I can enjoy every moment with my
lovely daughter anyway anyways to the
question
um I was listening to MMP that must be
fun to be in the Danish Navy nobody's
coming at you right
when was the last time a Danish ship got
[__] sunk World War II
going out to sea
as long as you're not on a submarine man
I wouldn't get claustrophobic I would
just be like guys it [__] stinks in
here
um
anyway where am I I was listening to
your MMP back in 2011.
which I can't believe was 12 years ago
Jesus Christ
and you mentioned that Pharaoh Islands a
Danish owned country is one of the
countries you wanted to visit or have a
stand-up show in I can assure you you
are well known here get the [__] out of
here as us Pharaoh East people don't
have much to do here other than
listening to idiot Americans
being triggered by dumb [__] it's
hilarious
um yeah it is pretty embarrassing I
think it's kind of over you know what I
like too is now the people that were
trying to cancel everybody are acting
like nobody got canceled it's like
classic abusive Behavior they do it and
then when you call them on it you know
when the the other shoe drops they're
like what that never happened
yeah what are you talking about like
class it's like your parents you [__]
did this to me well I never did that
um as I said you are very well known
here also in Denmark I I I've been to
Denmark a number of times
um I told a cab driver there to go [__]
himself too
[__] passive aggressive little
[__] [__] he was well he's actually
a foot taller than me but still
remember he pulled over he said
something because you Americans are so
stupid
oh I went off on him I remember Nia
dragging me out of the cab
you know not like I was gonna fight the
guy I just was just unloading on him
oh yeah you're so smart you drive a cab
you [__] giant [__]
come on Bill let's go we're in another
country no [__] him
what kind of a dick would do like if
some Danish guy came over here even if I
had some
feeling about Denmark I would never do
that because then I would be like every
time somebody brings up America he's
going to talk about me being an [__]
and how all Americans stink I don't do
that with Denmark just that [__] cab
driver
um anyway we love staying up here and
especially the yelling slash being
annoyed slash complaining kind so you
won't have trouble selling seats I mean
that's pretty much what I do uh I will
happily give you a tour in the islands
hey slow your roll here buddy I don't
even know who the [__] how do I know
you're not that cab driver from all
those years ago and you're gonna [__]
feed me to the Penguins
um I know you love motorcycles and I
funny enough own two Suzuki's let's go
riding in the mountains
yeah this guy's trying to murder me
anyways hope you read this and at the
very least considering come back here
you know what I gotta I gotta remember
where the Pharaoh Islands are
um
am I gonna get in trouble if I go there
were there there must have been other
people there before it's gonna be like
when Beyonce goes to [__] Dubai
they're like how could you go there
um all right hang on a second Pharaoh
Islands
pharaoh
islands all right
oh yeah yeah that's just oh this is part
of the uh the Nordic
that's the last one everybody forgets
right the Pharaoh Islands
like the not the Nordic the the scandin
part of scan to Scandinavia is within
the Nordic countries and Scandinavia is
Finland
Sweden Norway
Denmark in the Faroe Islands I believe
I believe I believe I can fly um the
Pharaoh Islands are simply pharaohs
um our North American island group and
an autonomous territory of the Kingdom
of Denmark It's [__] amazing England
didn't try to take that they just
stopped at Scotland
then took all the potatoes in Ireland I
have all my life I never knew that the
[__] potato family was a genocide
no idea
I just thought it was like the Dust Bowl
and they couldn't grow [__] potatoes
ah American public schools uh they are
located 320 kilometers north northwest
of the United Kingdom and about halfway
from Noe the island is part of the
Kingdom of Denmark along with the
demographic
terrain is rugged subpolar
what's up polar hey [__] oh it's
actually South
east of Iceland
terrain is rugged
I don't know guys
temperatures for such a Northerly
climate are moderate by the Gulf Stream
okay I'm back in I'm back in 12 degrees
Celsius 54 Fahrenheit 5 degrees Celsius
41. I like this
Civil Twilight during the summer nights
is very short
and very short-winded
oh the Northerly latitude also results
In Perpetual Civil Twilight during the
summer nights and very short winter days
oh wow yeah that'll [__] with you after
a while
um
this is not answering what I want to do
all right I was trying to impress you
guys that I knew a little bit of
geography and
didn't go the way I thought it was going
to go all right we're just going to call
that a loss because I'm not going to
[__] type with one hand
I'm not going to try to type Scandinavia
with one [__] hand
I couldn't do it with two so you know
it's part of being 54. you give up on
your dreams you know your limits all
right TSA security check
um hey Bill love your podcast thank you
I just went through TSA security in
Detroit and it made me think of you I'm
pregnant so I opted out of the full body
scan machine the TSA agent was very
polite to me but also tried to tell me
that it was just a song a sonar machine
I declined it was given a full pat down
and sent on my way a sonar machine
the only sonar I know his drums
played by the great Phil Rudd
played by the great Steve Smith who else
is a sonar artist
oh my [__] brain is going to Mush um
the TSA agent was very polite to me but
also tried to tell a sonar machine Oh
you mean like uh like trying to find
whales like a fish finder really I've
been trying to fact check that statement
for the past 20 minutes and I found
nothing anyway all the best to you and
your family well good for you
good for you
you know
that's
I'm not saying all TSA people are are
bad but that person definitely should be
selling used cars if that's what the
[__] they're saying what is a sonar
machine
oh s-o-n-a-r
but it said the same way right
all right finding a couple of buddies
um
Hey Oh Billy bail bags ball bags sorry
Isaac going here finding a couple of
buddies hey old Billy ball bags I'm 40
years old happily married have a good
career play tennis regularly look at you
look at you you [__] snooty cut you
Posh [__] as they say
over in England you play tennis
regularly oh do you you play in your
Wimbledon whites
huh
you [__] playing a grass surface you
[__] cozy [__]
um huh what's your thread count on your
sheets
um I own a home and two rental
properties well look at you and live in
a great neighborhood in North Carolina
oh Bluegrass coat quartz moved here
about 20 years ago from New York oh this
guy was ahead of the [__] curve
oh my God
I can't imagine the house that you
bought if you had New York money and
then moved to North Carolina 20 years
ago
supplies they didn't immediately make
you the mayor
um I've been disabled since birth oh
Jesus
there's always a [__] left turn what
do you mean you're disabled and use a
wheelchair [__]
generally I'm crushing it out there yes
you are and life is good
wait a minute you're in a wheelchair and
you're playing tennis
what you play tennis regularly do you
play against another guy in a wheelchair
or you got one of those old people
[__] uh
carts that zip around like 20 miles an
hour you bet your Baseline game must be
incredible
uh one thing seems to be missing
finding a couple of close Buddies
wait a minute you're playing tennis who
are you playing with
he said I didn't have much to do I
didn't have too much difficulty making
friends as a kid
or have too much difficulty wait another
day or in college in New York I do have
a couple of guys that I hang out with
Once in a rare while but have had few
consistent friends since College
I mean I was so [__] psyched for this
guy no okay all right we got to help
this person here I do think being in a
wheelchair has limited opportunities to
some extent but I know that it's not the
whole story people have careers families
and are busy but also get set aside but
also can set aside guy time too what's a
guy got to do around here to find some
dudes to hang out with thanks and go
[__] yourself oh I see what happened
this is what happened oh you're happily
married
I thought you were the person that
stayed single if you stay single in your
40s
by then everybody's pretty much you know
locked down and then living a life and
you just don't have look look at me I
mean look how great the Bruins are
playing I don't have time to [__] do
that forget about go down the street you
know get my ass kicked by some guy in a
[__]
you know 30 mile an hour wheelchair
whatever you're doing are you hustling
these people when you're playing [__]
tennis is that what it is you took all
their money and like you know [__] that
guy
um
what's a guy gotta do well I mean
first of all you're playing tennis
in North Carolina I would think that's a
very small
portion of the population and I am going
to get stereotypical here stock cars
isn't what it used to be
um
that's a tough one you're also married
you got a good career
um you got two rental properties you got
any kids
is it because you don't have kids
you know what I would do I would [__]
I would cast a wide net
I would literally look at you know how
to meet people you know things to do for
40 year olds start there knowing that
you're not going to do 99 of that just
to kind of give you like a direction to
point
you know you're cheering
sorry I gotta go with the material you
give me buddy
um
hmm
if I was 40
I wish I was 40.
and I moved to a new era I didn't have
any friends uh usually the local bar
um
anyone need a bar fly
I would expect do you have any other
Hobbies tennis that's a rough one
I feel like tennis peaked like 40 years
ago
when everyone was into Jimmy Connors and
Mcenroe and Bjorn Borg I just feel like
you know there's probably more women
playing tennis because I feel like the
the
well you went into Pete Sampras
and then there was that other guy
and then there's that other guy Nadal
right you know
ah dude you got me here what the f you
know what I'm gonna do your [__]
homework for you North Carolina
here we go I'm gonna do this with one
[__] hand here
yeah
things
wait
how
okay casting a wide net how to meet
people
in
North
Carolina
in there
40s
no clan members please all right date my
age meet travel mates 10 best dating
dating meet new friends over 40 groups
Raleigh North Carolina the capital here
we go join meet up
let's see here
triangle 30s 40s 50s social fun group
Chapel Hill Durham fun with friends
women who laugh
over 40.
Laff
I wonder what that stands for
uh classy ladies mid 40s 50s like you're
not trying to [__] around here Urban 40s
50s 60s lgbtq
Carolina aging triangle
there's a bunch of people my age living
life large singles
six singles at seven ladies brunch
all right so this [__] website stinks
all right all right okay on a second
hang on how to make friends and meet
people as an adult
make friends through volunteer work
there's an ambulance an ambulance
there's an abundance I said there's an
ambulance there's an abundance of
volunteer opportunities anywhere you
live in North Carolina volunteering
there you go
there you go I gave you a lead try
volunteering it's a good thing to do it
makes you feel good
and then you can meet other nice people
that actually give a [__] about other
people unless they're running a corrupt
um charity which it does happen all
right etiquette
oh I forgot to mention you I just
watched Jimmy Kimmel's uh monologue on
the Oscars I thought it was [__]
great the tone of it was perfect you
know he was funny
a little self-deprecation he's poking
fun at people but he's not going too
hard no one jumped up on the stage I
think it was all right
um etiquette
um hail groundskeeper Billy uh I went to
a Halifax Mooseheads hockey game that
sounds fun on the weekend it had an
absolute the absolute privilege to sit
behind one of the opposing team's
players parents number 25 to be exact
after the Moosehead jumped up to a 5-1
lead in the first things started getting
a little chippy for some pretext the
Mooseheads play in the qmjhl which has
teams in some very small towns and
cities Halifax has one of the largest
cities in the league also one of the
largest and boisterous fan bases the
players age ranges from 16 to 20.
so the NHS this is like hoop dreams but
the NHL
uh that being said Halifax was playing a
team from a city of about 20 000 people
so for some of these younger players
from smaller towns this is their first
time playing in front of larger crowds
there was just under 9 000 people at the
game that's pretty impressive and they
all decided that they hated number 25
whose parents I was sitting behind
sitting behind he had slew footed one of
our players well that'll do it took some
dumb penalties and was taking all kinds
of [__] on the Jumbotron still being
down five to one by the way
um he was trying to draw players into
fights and taking penalties he's the guy
who stirs it up as the booze rained down
on him every time he touched the puck
his mother would cheer as loud as she
could that's a great mom so my section
would boo louder than any other section
to drown out or cheering I'll give this
lady some credit she was able to
withstand a barrage of your sons a bum
heckles for two periods until she got up
with five five minutes into the third
period see that see that Michael Moore
with your [__] fairy dust that you
sprinkle over Canada like they're all
these [__] nice people they're
animals [__] animals
having said that I wish I saw that I
wish I was at that game anyway
oh no
I shouldn't have said that because the
next sentence says she got up with tears
in her eyes
and walked up the stairs to a round of
sarcastic Applause from my section
wow
alcohol everybody uh takes a lot of
courage to cheer for your son in a
losing game after he became the punching
bag for the entire crowd the dad just
sat in his seat and enjoyed the game
almost embracing the booing
though you know what he's got really
well-balanced parents
you know good for that number 25. uh
just wanted I don't know mine is the
Slew Foot just wanted to get your
thoughts on this we were we too hard on
the mom or is that what you get when you
cheer for the away team that's what you
get if your kids out there slew footing
people I mean it you know
she needs to toughen up a little bit but
not too much because I bet she's a great
mom I mean I gotta be honest with you
man that's a hell of a mom
you know anyway come back to Halifax
soon Bill been 10 years since you came
up here with Versi has it really anyway
go [__] yourself you red [__]
um no thank you wait a second did I just
say I was going up to Halifax
I am just as you requested August 13th
I'll be up there and I will not be slew
footing anybody
um
I have a feeling there's a number of uh
there's a number of people right now
looking up slew foot
um anyway it's just basically
you kind of skate up beside a guy you
get yourself parallel with them you
stick your leg behind his legs and then
you put the elbow slash arm in the chest
and you just kind of go you just triple
you basically trip them backwards
you know you can really hurt somebody
doing it it's a [__] Dirtbag move
and uh if you do it in the opposing
Arena people are going to get booed if
you do it in the hometown Arena then
you'll be like that wasn't a penalty
and that's how it works
um all right that is the podcast
everybody
uh
um oh Billy [__] is is working out
he's got his freckled ass back in shape
I could go on tour get on stage now and
I would look all right and uh but I plan
on key I'm not stopping man I'm [__]
going until I'm shredded
like I was way back in the day oh Billy
[__] I have not had I told you last
time I had abs
I had ABS right up until I was about 27
28 years old
and uh
somebody introduced me to chili cheese
fries and I ate them and the next day my
belly was to set distended and it never
came back that was the last [__] time
I remember where I was and I could never
get it to come
back so um I'm working on that
I had a good four Big Macs sitting on my
stomach for a long [__] time and I'm
down to the last one the hardest one
you know
I got the little [__] belly the little
you know the the if if the top if you're
counting your abs starting from the top
left one two three four five six it's
five and six
of the [__] more so than seven
and eight
you know
the pubiscus
whatever [__] you call them um
those are the hard ones
AB seven and eight you know one and two
impressive three and four hey look at
you eyebrows up you get if you get if
you can get seven and eight no six no
five and six if you can get five and six
you you have seven and eight
that's just how that works
um
do I sound crazy good because I am all
right that's it go [__] yourselves and
I'll check in on you on Thursday
come on where the [__] the button